financial advice
for dummies okay i'm not saying you're a
dummy i'm not saying that i'm a dummy
i'm just saying that there are some
dummies out there and this is some
financial advice for the people out
there
so
um there's this guy
his name is jeremy schneider who he is
is almost irrelevant but his story is
very important he's a multi-millionaire
investor the guy's made millions and he
says if he can start all the way over
he'd put everything into one specific
investment called
a target date
index fund let's pull up this story
what's up so i'm all about this story
this like if you want to know what sizes
wheelhouse is bingo we got it
so i'm all about this the proof is
important i talked about invest in index
funds target date index fund etfs you
know set it and forget it let the good
times roll don't try to overthink it
don't try to beat the market just be in
the market it's not about day trading
it's about decade trading i say it all
the time and this guy just proved my
point so this guy jeremy shadow says
look i'm worth almost five million bucks
four and a half million bucks i see you
jeremy well done he says if i can start
all the way over i'd put all my money in
a target date index fund what is it so
basically i'm gonna oh you're you're
gonna learn how i need to learn so look
he's got all sorts of investments going
on we talked about index funds he's got
real estate he's got bonds he's got
stocks he's got businesses but again if
he can go back in a time machine and
start all the way over again he'd put it
into a target date index fund
specifically the v f i f x aka the
vanguard target date
retirement fund
he went about apple he went about amazon
he went about a house you want to buy
real estate he went about crypto
apparently
target date fund okay so you're right
saying what's that so let me just tell
you this guys backstory and we'll get
into what this stuff is all right so
basically he said
look i had to learn this the hard way i
started off in my 20s
by quote on quote doing dumb stock
picking on e-trade which is e-trade is
basically like back in the day robin
hood yeah which is robin is today and he
compared it to basically throwing
spaghetti
against the wall buying and selling
random stocks just because he oh i like
reddit sounds like uh give it a shot
yeah lose
um without any serious rhyme or reason
just throwing spaghetti on the wall and
see what sticks yeah that was his
mentality but then all of a sudden
target date index funds comes along and
i'll explain what that is we know what
index funds yeah right so rather than
picking a stock or a
bond you buy the entire s p 500 as an
example boom and rather than trying to
get in and get out and pick the stocks
that you think are going to win you buy
the entire market yeah buy the entire s
p 500 index fund it's not actively
invested it's passively invested so
you're paying a lower expense ratio it's
cheaper it's easier
you know it's not complicated you keep
it simple that's essentially what an
index fund is but a target date is
basically saying i want this money in
2040. or i want this money in 2050.
that's what i'm retiring okay or i want
this money by 2030
and
the target date essentially
it's a strategy based on that particular
date so let me break this down what this
means so it's all about risk when we
talk about investing it's all about risk
we all know risk return risk reward we
get it we get it we get it set and
forget it um
and you pick the target date of when you
want the money so for instance if you're
going to do a retirement fund a 401k
we talked about that's like the luggage
all right now you got to put clothes in
the luggage right so all right cool i'm
going to do an s p 500 index fund i'll
do it through vanguard when am i
touching this well i'm 25 years old so i
plan on retiring when i'm 65 so in 40
years so i'm gonna do a 2060
target date fund so meaning the younger
you are
the more risk you can take
right the older you are the less risk
can you take does that make sense to you
uh
keep going okay so let me explain risk
um
the younger you are yeah
right so it's interesting yeah so so if
you're if you if you're if it's money
that you need in the next six months a
year two years
just straight cash yeah don't invest
that stay like that just keep it in the
bank yeah put in a savings account put
it a check that's money you're gonna
need soon yeah if it's money you're
gonna need long term yeah three five 10
20 years down the road even longer
that's investing okay okay there's two
elements to investing time and compound
interest time and compound interest
right so
when you're young
you're investing horizon or your time
frame is longer dude i'm 25 years old i
i like the whole a lot of investing has
to do with retirement planning
retirement so i'm 65 years old how much
do i want the bank
zero
when i'm 65 no
half a million a million five million
like the more you have
you can retire and do nothing at a
certain age and we'll talk about that uh
further but the younger you are the more
risk you can take so when you talk about
risk
and risk tolerance
stocks
that stocks that's a heavily weighted
stock portfolio so maybe
you have 90 stocks in your portfolio
only 10 bonds because bonds are
basically for stability old people do
your old person impression oh i
remembered this bond i had exactly
matured exactly so when you're 60 years
old when you're 70 years old you're
retired
you're not going to have 90 stocks
that's risky bro that's certainly risky
you might go 70
bonds
30 stocks okay like if you want to know
anything about investing you want to
know anything about investing this is
all you need to know here it is folks do
this go ahead do this go ahead
the younger you are
the more stocks you should have okay
less bonds the older you are
the more bonds you should have less
stocks because the younger you are the
more risk you're really going to take i
got time the market fs up i see what
you're saying i got more time to gotcha
to make my money back risky the older
you are god forbid there's a correction
you're gonna lose all your freaking
money if you're all in stocks right this
is it
if there's anything you just gotta know
this is it guys record the screen right
now there it is you know david some
people are here
some people are here but where do we
want to be dave we want to be right here
we want to be up here this is what you
do up here that's what we want to do up
here
and that's what it comes about
it's weird i don't even so that's where
you want to be that's like seriously if
there's a
a a symbolic vision or metaphor to
investing young
stocks
old bonds and then just
john young john but if you're like hey
well i'm 50. are you young or you old at
that point i don't know so you're in the
middle oh oh maybe you're in the middle
50 stocks 50 bonds if you're 80 maybe 80
bonds 20 stocks
if you're 20
exactly if you're 20 maybe you're 80 90
stocks yeah 20 bucks that's it
that's it close the show
this is a drop the freaking mic
so again if you're you know 20 30 even
40 years old you can have 80 90 of your
portfolio into the stocks right and what
type of stocks maybe 50 percent you know
that's called a three fund portfolio
right so maybe the majority are in u.s
stocks s p 500 then you can have a
percentage that are in non-us stocks
global stocks right the world
world stocks emerging markets what have
you maybe 10 bonds
flip it if you're older and you're
retiring because you want to have more
stability right you're not looking for
growth when you're young you're looking
for growth you want your money to grow
when you're old you just don't want to
lose your money you want to have
stability right right that's why when
you're young you go out to the club baby
hell yeah when you're old
what do you do you just sit in your
rocking chair
what do you do you know maybe play a
little golf looking for stability
nothing crazy
yeah it's analogous analogous
all right so look
we did this we did like i don't pretend
to be like the investing guru and i'm
not warren buffett i'm not even mark
cuban okay but i know enough to know
that this makes
sense
when this guy says look here pull up his
portfolio scroll down a little bit
scroll down that's the guy he's worth
four and a half million bucks
congratulations jeremy schneider bingo
bango this is what his portfolio is now
here's how jeremy
four and a half million portfolio looks
right now he's got 52 percent in index
funds 27 percent in real estate 12 in
bonds right can we switch over to the to
the thing so the people can see i don't
know if you're going to see that
and then it's just sort of diversified
all right uh in a bunch of different
things
but the whole point of a target date
index funds is it's already diversified
for you so scroll down a little bit yeah
he says if you could go back in time and
do it all over again boom
100 into an index fund 100 into an index
fund so that just puts it out there for
you so look um again i'm not pretending
to be the investment guru i am a
personal finance expert like i know all
things personal finance
rent buy own car this happens to be
investing is a major part of that
major part of that okay but this is
exactly what i believe in this exactly
what i talk about okay i'm not a bit i'm
not a real estate guru i'm not a crypto
guru i do like investing in the stock
market but i understand personal finance
i understand when someone says look if i
can do it all over again target date
index fund it makes sense it adds up
again when he was younger he was
throwing spaghetti against the wall just
picking stocks who knows picking crypto
i like dogecoin i like tesla whatever it
is
okay you're just
gambling yeah this is a surefire way to
get 10 returns have your money grow over
time compound interest
let it grow let it go bro
all we talk is money
if you enjoyed that short clip from the
sauce cast click here to watch another
click here to watch the full episode or
just stay broken